vanos had many opportunities to kill all
of the Avengers and many of the heroes
all throughout the events of Avengers
infinity war but when it came down to it
fan OHS didn't go out of his way to kill
any of them except for one and that was
Tony Stark how's it going everyone it's
Warren and in this video I'm going to
talk about how Thanos hated Tony Stark
and how Tony was the only Avenger that
Thanos went out of his way to kill and
just a heads up I started a new giveaway
so if you would like to enter for your
chance to win five imax tickets so you
and some friends can go see Avengers
in-game or Captain Marvel in IMAX all
you have to do is be subscribed to my
channel with the notifications turned on
like the video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain so again Thanos had
many opportunities to kill many of the
different heroes in Avengers infinity
war but he never does sure he kills
Heimdall and he kills Loki but low key
was extremely personal and he never
really takes a jab at any of the main
heroes he had a great opportunity to
kill four on a ship but he doesn't he
just leaves him there in Wakanda he had
a great opportunity to kill Captain
America Black Widow Black Panther Bruce
Banner Groot war machine
Falcon Ikoyi and Scarlet Witch and then
on Titan he had the opportunity to kill
the majority of the guardians of the
galaxy Doctor Strange spider-man and
Iron Man but he didn't kill any of them
he just kind of got them out of the way
and thanks to the Russo brothers we know
why that is here's what the Russo
brothers had to say about fan OHS not
killing any of the Avengers Fei knows is
violent and cruel it's interesting
because Estanislao this armor he almost
becomes a holy warrior he doesn't spend
a lot of his energy intentionally trying
to murder people unless they are in some
way a threat to his agenda so Fanus
doesn't intentionally kill any of the
Avengers because they're not really a
threat to his agenda once he gets to
Infinity stones they're no match for him
and we even learned in the road to
infinity war artbook that fan OHS takes
off his armor once he gets to Infinity
stones because he doesn't need it
anymore he's just too powerful now so
none of the Avengers were a threat to
Thanos and he didn't go out of his way
to kill any of them except for Tony
Stark
Thanos knows who Tony Stark is we all
remember the scene
in Avengers infinity war where Thanos
realizes that he is fighting Tony Stark
Dawg you know me I do you're not the
only one cursed to acknowledge my only
curse is you after that scene Thanos and
Tony Stark fight in which stano's
defeats him and is about to kill him
until Doctor Strange intervenes but we
saw that Thanos was about to kill Tony
Stark with the Infinity Gauntlet
but why Tony is already incapacitated he
stabbed him in the stomach
Thanos clearly defeated him and got him
out of the fight so why did they nose
want to finish him well it's because it
was extremely personal for Thanos thanks
to the Russo brothers commentary we know
exactly how Thanos knew who Tony Stark
was and Avengers infinity war Joe Russo
said when it comes down to it Thanos no
stark as the man who thwarted his
efforts to take over Earth via Loki in
2012's the Avengers which is why he's
aware of Stark from the original battle
of New York as the person who undid the
plan so feyo's knows that it was Tony
Stark who undid his plan in the Battle
of New York in the first Avengers movie
and defeated his army Tony also kept
Thanos his army from conquering planet
Earth and it cost Thanos two Infinity
stones so phantos had a plan to collect
the Infinity stones before but Tony
undid his plan this gives Thanos a
little bit of respect for Tony Stark but
ultimately leads him to hate him for
being the person who comes in the way of
him collecting the Infinity stones and
balancing the universe which is why Fano
said I hope they remember you but was
about to kill him because it was
extremely personal so that's why Fanus
wanted to kill Tony Stark and none of
the other Avengers let me know what you
think about this and the comments down
below and also let me know if you think
we're going to see a really awesome
rematch between Tony Stark and Thanos
and Avengers endgame let me know in the
comments down below and don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date on everything relating to
Avengers in game as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof
[Music]
you